all right turning now to our series the
dish and this morning we're focusing on
a condiment strong in flavor and
tradition it's called chili crisp but
it's got a long history in china but now
its popularity is booming all around the
world including right here in america
leading brand lao
gan ma is inspiring new chefs to put
their own spin on the red hot topping
and for this asian american pacific
islander heritage month nancy chen sat
down with one chef who adds her
signature chili crisp to just about
everything
crunchy and textured i love that sizzle
a bright collision of chilies and spices
simmered in oil smells really good
chinese chili crisp isn't spicy hot but
the condiment is on fire
long ladled onto classic asian dishes
like dumplings noodles and stir fries
chili crisp is exploding in popularity
even expanding to the desert menu
is there anything you can't put it on i
have yet to find something you can't put
it on if it's edible you can put it on
chef and fly by jing ceo jin gao adds
her unique spin to the traditional
topping by sourcing 18 ingredients
exclusively from her hometown in citroen
china red chilies that are
fruity
mild heat super fragrant the high
quality ingredients from chengdu
including sichuan pepper and fermented
black beans aren't readily available
elsewhere but gao gave us an idea how
they all come together in her los
angeles kitchen what is the appeal here
is it the spiciness the texture there's
something about it you can't really put
your finger on but somehow it just works
with everything right it is basically
just the components of chilies and oil
but when you add in those extra layers
that's what gives the chili crisp the
extra dimension of flavor and now the
flavors are infused into the oil
families in china have enjoyed their own
time honored recipes that's mappu tofu
right there yes
but it became widely commercialized when
a chinese noodle maker bottled and
branded her version lag and ma now
produces more than a million jars a day
for fans in more than 30 countries we're
playing a part in preserving that
tradition by pushing it forward by
introducing it to new audiences a
culture and a tradition if it doesn't
evolve it dies so we want to play a part
in evolving it in our own way after
leaving her tech industry job gow opened
a restaurant in shanghai focused on
locally sourced ingredients before
traveling the world as a chef in pop-up
kitchens for
a very long time people had not just a
lack of awareness about what chinese
cuisine was but also
additional bias against it like that
it's
oily that is oily that it's unhealthy
that it's low quality and should be
cheap
right and so if those are the attitudes
that people have towards chinese cuisine
then there's no incentive for anybody to
really bring anything of quality out
it's about more than just the food too
when you talk about those perceptions
absolutely in 2018 gal launched a viral
kickstarter campaign to fund her own
signature chili crisp
and with more people cooking at home
during the pandemic her company has
grown tenfold churning out nearly a
million jars in the past year
the u.s chile crisp craze isn't limited
to store shelves and kitchen counters
restaurants are also making it their own
that's two really good things together
famed brooklyn pizza maker paulie g
recently partnered with family-run
sheehan famous foods for a pie centered
around their secret recipe made up of 30
fragrant spices this is she on famous
pizza what do the chili crisps add to
this
texture
even with more than 50 pizzas on the
menu g says this one quickly became a
hit after its debut
we're eating
pizza that's made out of an oven that
came from italy and it's using spice
that is inspired by something that
people in china have been eating for
centuries and it's all made here in
america
our goal is to
change the conversation about chinese
food to
elevate its status in our culture so
we're really here to
uplift all marginalized cultures not
just chinese and we're doing so through
flavor a melting pot of taste melding
together tradition and innovation i have
made a version of a mezcal paloma
there's a rim of mala spice oh and then
a little bit of the chili crisp oil
well cheers cheers
nancy chen joins us right now with the
early morning treat and a little bit
oh okay
you don't get to eat ice cream very
often at 8 30 in the morning
so we can do it any time we want
actually i make my own rules you said if
it's for work calories don't count okay
that's the way i work so we have ice
cream vanilla ice cream here with a
little bit of chili crisp on top is that
a common thing to put it in it is you
really believe you can put it on
everything on anything i have tried it
normally with stir fries with noodles
with dumplings but this is something a
little new and it's a nice i think
contrast between the the chili
and also how vanilla it is speaking of
somebody who is traveling here for three
two hit particular ice cream shops who's
a big big ice cream guy this is very
good
i really like that i really like this
and you've tried this before tony i've
made homemade chili crisp but i've never
put it on ice cream before yeah i put it
on greek yogurt but this actually really
hits i like it look at nancy teaching us
something new what do you think of it
fancy i like it i would like it on pizza
too mm-hmm you have a pizza pie back
there you know let me get that for you
in the next commercial break
but it actually tastes better than i
thought it would to be honest
got a pizza pie back there a burger
pizza pie or carnivore or a burger too
nancy thank you for it good to see you
here